the 2018 nfl mvp pat from homes one of
the great quarterback seasons of all
time this is the no look pass if you are
looking at nbcsn right now
he won that mvp award as i mentioned and
he is the favorite to win it again 7-2
according to caesar's entertainment the
official nfl partner when it comes to
casino gambling so who are the most
likely candidates chris to win the nfl
mvp award for the first time in their
careers we've been talking about a
couple of guys who've never won it today
carson wentz and philip rivers who do
you like to win it who has yet to hold
that that uh that trophy that they gave
out the night before the super bowl all
right well there's two guys that jump
out to me okay the the first guy i'm
gonna throw out there is andrew luck all
right andrew luck to this point of
course has not won an mvp and the way
that team set up the offense they run
you know i would be shocked if they fell
off the earth i would think they're
going to be a playoff team once again to
where yeah i look at that and go oh
watch out second year in this system a
little more talent around them again and
one of the best if not the best
offensive line in the game andrew luck
would be a guy i'd go okay watch out for
um go ahead you i want you to go next
before i just rattle off names go ahead
the the way that we've got the the
seizures odds but they're not arranged
according to the the lowest to the
highest
actually number two on the list is
andrew luck at six to one okay patrick
holmes is seven to two luck is six to
one and then tom brady carson wentz and
phillip rivers are all seven to one each
okay so uh i you know i'm intrigued by
that i'm intrigued by baker mayfield at
nine to one because if the browns live
up to their potential this year he's the
guy who's going to get the praise he's
the guy who's going to get the credit
remember at the end of the day there's
nothing objective about the mvp vote 50
sports writers and broadcasters many of
whom are covering only one team and
others are covering the whole league and
baker mayfield he's got that name
already that's going to resonate if the
browns are good yeah that's what it's
driven by it's the best quarterback on
the best team who ends up winning the
ready award not the guy who has the best
year per se and if the browns now i
don't think the browns are going to be
13 and three but if they go wire to wire
and they have one of the top seeds in
the afc and baker mayfield is the reason
why they improve he's going to be a
candidate for mvp yeah no question mike
he was one of the guys i wrote down too
yeah i mean i'm glad you described the
mvp that way too because that's the way
it is you're right it's the best
quarterback on the best team you know
that's got wins and the stats to justify
it and yeah baker mayfield i don't know
if they got to be a number one or a
number two seed but gosh if they got in
the playoffs and they were a five and
six seeded eleven and five or ten and
six and that offense and he pulled out
magic all year with odell and jarvis
landry i'd have a hard time believing he
wasn't it wouldn't be at the top of that
discussion hey ben roethlisberger is
another guy that comes to my mind right
off the bat you know it sets up for him
for everything you're saying too oh
didn't make the playoffs last year what
if they win the division this year oh
and there's no antonio brown and he has
a big gear and there's no le'veon bell
and all that i think that could set up
and then plus you could get a little bit
like what we saw with drew brees last
year where it's like man he's never won
the mvp before he deserves it i feel
like ben roethlisberger could be that
guy if he throws for 4 800 yards and 40
touchdowns watch out no
no here's the problem that means better
rothers burger yeah
you're going to say that right and
they're not going to want to vote for
him that's why he's a 30-1 underdog to
win the thing i saw 30 to one and i
thought hey this is a pretty good bet
then i started thinking you know what
i yeah
media members vote for him
not going to want to vote for ben
rothersberger think about it a couple
years ago antonio brown was the mvp
candidate on the steelers not and
i mean one of the reasons it's it's
never gone to a receiver is that if
there's a receiver who's good enough to
be considered for mvp the quarterback's
the one who's going to get the votes
you're right so but roethlisberger has
never been he's he hasn't been a super
bowl mvp you could argue he should have
been in 2008 that was before the
off-field stuff the off-field stuff i
think is what really drags him down even
though it's been nearly a decade later i
don't think enough of the 50 members of
the media will vote for ben
roethlisberger no matter what kind of
season that he has i also see ezekiel
elliott at 50-1 i mean now he's another
one i don't think he even though he's
had the off-field incident not to the
same degree as roethlisberger i mean i
could see if the cowboys are great this
year elliot or dak prescott and i'm
looking for dak prescott on here he's 50
to one as well yeah between the two of
them i probably would say if the cowboys
are great prescott's going to get more
of that mvp buzz than elliot so i think
we can't overlook him and at fifty to
one that may be a good one to take a
flyer that is you talk you said 50 to
one if you got extra change around yeah
throw that one down i'm with you mike
yeah they go 12 and four you know just
like we saw the rookie of the year when
dak prescott and ezekiel were both up
for it dak prescott got it i don't know
if he necessarily agreed to that i
deserved to i think ezekiel did but he
was the quarterback and they were 13 and
three and he did a lot of good things so
i'm with you mike that would be one that
would certainly be a dark horse
candidate for me i'm gonna throw two
others out that just jump out to me okay
russell wilson we don't talk about that
enough he's a guy that certainly can be
in that combo and my real dark horse
would be jimmy garoppolo jimmy garoppolo
like you've talked about it sets up oh
the 49ers change their you know their
season around and they get into the
playoffs and of course kyle shannon and
that offense and they got a good old
line and a running game and you know a
stable of receivers to go along with
george kittle where i could see you know
the 49ers being a playoff team and
garoppolo you know statistically being
one of the three or four best
quarterbacks in football and him being
that dark horse mvp candidate
how about saquon barkley at 60 to one i
mean if he has a huge huge year 22 2300
yards from scrimmage already had 2 000
last year i think the giants would have
to make the playoffs it almost have to
be what adrian peterson did yeah in 2012
where the team just barely makes the
playoffs and the player has a flat out
phenomenal
season not not not quite you know 2100
yards rushing but if if barkley just has
a special season receiving and running
and generating yards and touchdowns i
think barkley at 61 would be very
intriguing all right royal ascot is up
next on nbcsn but pro football talk live
continues on nbc sports radio and on
nbcsports.com will have our wednesday
draft when pft live returns right after
this
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports